hop le monde du béton repousse chaque
jour un peu plus la nature les champs et
les oiseaux et chaque jour un peu plus
l'homme devient davantage prisonniers
pourtant ils restent parfois comme
oubliée au milieu de grands ensembles un
endroit où quelques oiseaux viennent
encore chanter question à 13 ans son
enfance difficile dans les cités hlm des
alentours son retard à l'école l'ont
amené à se replier sur lui même il n'a
pas beaucoup d'amis les seuls vrais amis
de christian ce sont les oiseaux les
oiseaux qu'ils essaient d'attraper pour
les emmener chez lui
ces oiseaux bien sûr ils les mettent en
cage mais peut-être peut-être leur part
le filet
[Musique]
je calme il te dire je chasse
et bien lieu
la chaîne trends
c'est l'abus sont épatants remettre les
pics 1
j'aimerais me sortir la pole à le mettre
à côté de benfica c'est sûr d'honorer
qui chantonne pour appeler les autres
je l'a passée à attendre simple et le
chien la couleur simple de les voir si
vos les tracas gens ils ont chanteur
parce qu'ils s'entendent ils parlent
tiens tu as pu le mettre dans une cage à
plainte je laisse toujours un cage après
germaine à la chasse à l'oie six chaînes
y en a qui sont vieux qui chante mieux
que que les jeunes et celui-là dubois
qui va chanter bien oui ça reste un beau
mâle jettera pas le plus simple des
chardonnerets le plus tout jeune et 7
une fois que j'atteins les oiseaux je
les mets en cage des fois ils sont tous
nés ils chantent part ça m'ennuie
pourquoi parce que ça ne peut pas car je
ne raisonne pas gelé babil relâche pour
qu'après je les reconnais quand je les
attrape
mais christian quand tu mets un oiseau
en cage
est ce que tu crois pas au bout d'un an
qu'il est un peu prisonnier ici je 500
prisonniers parce que il bouge sa folle
de la plage qu'est ce que tu fais
franchir la star je ferai le verbe haut
et pourquoi
[Musique]
ce palais
et oh
[Musique]
oui mais